it is march 17 2022 and you're watching
the code report it's about time we had a
talk about time you would think it's a
pretty simple concept time began on
january 1st 1970 with the unix epic at
any moment we can get the number of
milliseconds elapsed from this date on
any computer using a method like date
now this is called incremental time but
one problem is that the earth doesn't
rotate evenly because it's actually flat
and the international earth rotation
service occasionally mandates a leap
second where an additional second is
added to the last minute of the day
things start getting weird when we talk
about time zones which are calculated
relative to greenwich mean time on the
pacific we subtract eight hours but in
newfoundland they only subtract three
and a half hours and in nepal they add
five and three quarters then daylight
savings comes around and all the time
zones change except in places like
arizona and hawaii that don't do a time
change in the south pacific they're 13
hours ahead which requires them to skip
an entire day you could celebrate new
year's on christmas island spend the
entire next day recovering from your
hangover then fly to jarvis island in
time to celebrate new year's eve again
now when it comes to the entire year the
gregorian calendar is a ridiculous
abstraction some months have 28 days
while others have 31 but every other
counting system we use like weeks and
days have consistent intervals it
doesn't have to be this way the
cotsworth plan which was presented in
1902 divides the year into 13 months
each month with four weeks or 28 days
with one rest day somewhere in the
middle it makes so much more sense and
aligns better with the lunar cycle for
developers it would make the complicated
matter of finding the duration of
multiple months a simple matter of
multiplying by 28 but there may be some
good news when it comes to keeping track
of time there's a bill going through
congress right now to get rid of
daylight savings honestly it doesn't go
far enough and i wish they would also
get rid of the gregorian calendar this
could be bad news though for low-level
systems programmers who figured out all
these weird rules with time zones i
imagine this is the type of code that
nobody wants to touch but if we get rid
of daylight savings somebody will have
to go in there and change things
speaking of changes there is a stage 3
proposal for the temporal api in
javascript which would make it much
easier to work with dates and times the
current date implementation in
javascript goes all the way back to 1995
when brendan ike had 10 days to write
the language the overlords at netscape
wanted it to be kind of like java so he
copied the java implementation which for
lack of a better word was a total piece
of even java overhauled that api back in
97 but in javascript we still have the
pleasure of using it and not
surprisingly recent polling data
indicates that it's one of the most
hated features in javascript there are
libraries like moment.js and date
functions that improve many of its
shortcomings but it would be nice to
have something better built in when
getting the current time in javascript
it only gives you the milliseconds
however the new api would also give you
microseconds nanoseconds and other
formats that you might find useful an
even bigger problem though is that it's
difficult to compute times for a
specific time zone but the temporal api
would fix that by providing a time zone
aware object it would also make it much
easier to compute values between dates
and simplifies the process of working
with dates in a variety of different
ways looks awesome but i'm afraid we've
run out of time for our session today
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one